A lack of sleep is dangerous.
We’re often told not to drive whilst tired
and falling asleep at the wheel can be fatal.
During World War II many sleep-deprived pilots
fell asleep mid-flight and crashed their plane
on the way home from the war zone.
In fact, you may be horrified to hear that
in a study, 56% of consumer aircraft pilots
admitted to falling asleep in the cockpit
whilst the plane was in autopilot.
It’s fair to say that our body needs sleep
but how long could you theoretically stay
awake for?
Could a person die if they were forced to
stay awake for a long time?
And what happens to your mind and your body
when you miss out on sleep?
Let’s find out.
If you live to 78 you will have spent around
25 years asleep.
But what if you can’t sleep?
Well It’s not as simple as that.
Eventually your brain will make you sleep.
After only a couple of days the urge to sleep
will become greater than the urge to eat.
At this point you might experience a phenomenon
known as microsleep.
This is when your brain forces you to sleep
for a short time without you being aware.
Microsleep is a common symptom amongst insomnia
sufferers.
Your brain suddenly shuts down, but your eyes
remain open.
It can last for a few seconds or a few minutes.
During microsleep the person’s eyes usually
remain wide open but they will have a blank,
distant stare.
They will go into a brief, zombie-like state
and won’t respond to any outside information.
You’ve probably experienced microsleep,
if you’ve ever drove for a long period of
time on the motorway or highway, on very little
sleep.
It’s that feeling when you blank out for
a couple of seconds and it feels like you
lost a brief period of time but you don’t
remember actually falling asleep.
As you can probably imagine, microsleep is
the cause of many accidents.
Microsleep is your brain’s way of going
“Okay dude I know you’re trying to stay
awake at the moment, but I’m really tired,
you carry on as you are, I’m just gonna
catch a few z’s for a minute.
Okay?”
But when it comes to wanting to sleep, some
people don’t have a choice.
A rare genetic disease called Fatal Familial
Insomnia or FFI, prevents people falling asleep
at all.
It affects around just forty families worldwide.
The disease destroys the area of the brain
that controls when we sleep, the thalamus.
Sufferers of FFI will experience progressively
worse insomnia, after a while they start to
hallucinate and eventually they will because
extremely confused, similar to dementia patients,
and then, they will eventually die.
The average lifespan for someone with this
tragic and scary disease is just eighteen
months.
But even for the regular person a lack of
sleep can have severe effects on the body
and can even be fatal.
After missing just one night of sleep the
first thing you will notice is a decrease
in cognitive function.
First and foremost, a lack of sleep impairs
attention, concentration, reasoning, problem
solving and your ability to learn.
But perhaps what’s even scarier is that
by missing out on sleep you can wipe whole
days from your memory.
It’s believed that during sleep our brain
consolidates, organises and permanently stores
that day’s memories and what we learnt.
If you don’t get enough sleep, instead of
storing those memories forever, your brain
will simply forget them altogether.
But that’s only scratching the surface.
Continual sleep loss over a period of several
days or more can have substantially worse
effects on the body.
Chronic sleep loss or insomnia has been linked
to a significant increase in heart disease,
strokes, diabetes, obesity and depression.
In fact, a study showed that over 90% of people
with insomnia also suffer from another serious
health condition.
Oh and sleep also keeps you looking young.
It’s during sleep that the growth hormone
is released that repairs tissue, keeping those
wrinkles at bay.
When you don’t get much sleep, specifically
slow-wave sleep, your body doesn’t get an
opportunity to repair itself, so you age faster.
Not only that but when you miss out on sleep
your body releases the stress hormone cortisol
which actually breaks down skin collagen,
the protein that keeps your skin smooth, bouncy
and looking mighty fine.
Sleep loss, even a few missed hours per night,
causes droopy, yellowish skin, puffy eyes,
fine lines and dark circles.
So now you know why you really, really shouldn’t
miss out on sleep.
But how long could you, theoretically stay
awake?
If you were forced to stay awake by an evil
scientist who strapped you to a chair, Clockwork
Orange-style, and gave you a quick electric
shock every time you started to drift, how
long would it take before your body gave up,
and what would be the consequence?
The answer to the question how long can humans
stay awake for is 264 hours, or about 11 days.
In 1947 a 16-year-old high school student
in San Diego, California named Randy Gardner
set the world record for the longest scientifically
documented case of someone going without sleep,
without using stimulants.
Gardner stayed awake for 264 hours, or 11
days.
Before Gardner’s attempt there were many
attempt to stay awake for a prolonged period
and since then there have been many more.
The current record holder is Tony Wright,
a man from the south of England who broke
Garner’s record by just two hours, staying
awake for 266 hours.
Noticing the trend here?
Almost everyone who’s attempted to break
the record hits a road block at around 11
days.
That seems to be the bodies limit.
In fact, many researchers have attempted to
stay awake over the years and the average
period they reach is eight to ten days.
After which the urge to sleep becomes far
too overwhelming, to continue fighting against.
There haven’t been any recorded cases of
someone staying awake for longer than eleven
consecutive days.
But if they did, could it result in death?
In the sleep laboratory at the University
of Chicago an experiment was conducted on
rats to find out if sleep deprivation can
kill.
Rats were put on a rotating disc which was
suspended over a pool of water.
Sensors were attached to the rats to record
their brain waves and a computer program was
setup to analyse those brain waves and detect
when the rats were about to fall asleep.
At which point the disc would spin faster,
meaning if the rats fell asleep and didn’t
steady themselves on the rapidly spinning
disc, they would inevitably fall into the
water below.
This harsh treatment prevented the rats from
sleeping at all, for risk of falling into
the water.
I know, us humans do some rather horrendous
things in the pursuit of knowledge.
So was this horrific experiment worth anything?
What did we learn?
Well, all the rats that underwent the experiment
eventually died from a lack of sleep.
The average lifespan of the rats was 11-32
days.
The scientists conducting the experiment believed
the cause of death to be whole body hypermetabolism,
a condition which causes extreme weight loss,
and if not remedied, death.
The hypermetabolism was most likely brought
on by the lack of sleep.
It’s highly likely that if a human were
to stay awake for much longer than eleven
days then hypermetabolism would kick in and
cause one’s eventual demise.
Or some other equally extreme condition brought
on by sleeplessness.
Although it’s believed to have happened
at some point in history, after all, sleep-deprivation
has been used as a method of torture.
There has never been a case well documented
enough, to study the effects of forcing someone
to stay awake and so, scientists aren’t
exactly sure what would happen.
But, just like the rats, the general consensus
is that if one were to stay awake for much
longer than eleven consecutive days, they
would most certainly die.
The cause of death wouldn’t be sleeplessness,
there’s no such condition, it would be some
horrific side-effect brought on from not sleeping.
For example, hypermetabolism, as was the case
with the rats.
Although, the body’s urge to sleep is so
strong that this almost never happens, so
there is very little evidence to be able to
know for certain what exactly would be the
cause of death, at least in the case of humans.
But, just to be safe, try not to miss out
on your precious beauty sleep, because if
you do it enough, it very well, could, kill
you.